Alright. I want you to guess my word, using this hill
climbing approach that we've just been
talking about. And unfortunately, well, we
tried this will actual words and the space is a little bit
big and frustrating. But what we can do instead is pretend that
a five bit sequence is a word. So, I'm thinking of
a word and by word I mean five bits. And what we're
going to do is I'm going to give you, for each time you guess
a 5-bit sequence, I'm going to tell you the number of correct bits.
So in each position it's, it's, if you matched what I am
thinking in that position, then I give you an additional point for that.
>> Okay.
>> And you're going to now step
through the hill-climbing algorithm. Okay, so three
things. 1, if you had done eight bits, that would be a word. And.
>> Oh. Nice.
>> 2, four bits is a nibble. Okay, here's
the third thing. We need to define a neighbor function.
So, I'm going to define a neighbor function. So, I can think
about this. This is all one bit differences from where you are.
>> That's good and, and an interesting question is, was it your
job to come up with that or was it my job to come
up with that? Now is it, is it part of the problem
or is it part of the algorithm that's trying to solve the problem?
>> Huh. I'm going to say it's a part
of the algorithm that's trying to solve the problem.
>> That's how I think of it, too.
>> Alright, so, we have to start
somewhere, so let's just pretend for the sake
of argument that we start it at all five zeros.
>> And I'm going to give you a score of two for that.
>> Okay. And so now I have to do all possible neighbors, and there are five
of them. So there is one followed by four zeros. 01 followed by
three zeroes and you know, the rest of the identity.
>> Alright, here is all your neighbors for the x, you're aware.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And here is the scores for all of those neighbors.
>> So,
there are three of them that are maximal
but for the sake of simplicity and drawing,
I am going to stick with the first one. So you can get rid of the bottom four.
>> Alright, so here is our new x.
>> Okay. And now I have to try
all different. So one of the neighbors would be
all zeroes. But I already know what that
is. So I don't have to worry about that.
>> That's good. So the algorithm, the
pseudocode that we wrote didn't do that,
do that optimization but in general if
as long as the neighborhood function is symmetric
then you can save yourself a little bit of effort.
>> Right, so, or we can just keep track of everything that we've ever seen,
although that gets very space inefficient very quickly.
And since it's the identity maker's [UNKNOWN] with
the one matrix. [LAUGH] Okay, so what are the numbers to that one? Wow, that's
pretty cool! So, you said we're getting there
very quickly. So, it's going to be, so, [CROSSTALK]
>> In fact, we now, have enough information, that
smart human being could actually jump to the, optimum.
>> Yeah, I
think we do. I was actually thinking about that.
>> Let's see what happened.